[Music]
[Applause]
hey marble fans I'm Ryan panade Gauss
aka agent M and I'm so excited to be
sitting here with VFX Supervisor of
Marvel Studios avengers endgame dandelo
hey dude am doing great so there's so
much to talk about in this film you
worked three years on it I let's just
dive right into some sky you ready yep
you know think about this big battle
how much creative input do you have in
seeing all this coming together you know
you get kind of a rough idea of what the
story needs to be get a rough idea from
like Joe and Anthony it's like okay like
you know this these are the beats we
want to do we want the cup unbound to
blow up we want to make a crater yeah
and this is kind of where the dreams
come true you know in terms of like
growing up loving comics loving films
and then kind of getting to design these
fights you know when you're you know
kind of describe it as you got your
casual action figures in head when
you're kid now they're like you're grown
up you're doing the same thing except
with real people and stun tease and CG
characters and you kind of sit down and
start brainstorming it's like well what
you know what has to happen you know and
it's like you know caps gonna pick up
millionaire Maggie is he's going to take
up it's going to take up a hammer one
way or another so you get to the moment
where the portals start opening up how
many layers are going on in a shot like
that I it's pretty I mean astronomical
so kind of an easy way to describe it we
had our big days where we had everybody
there you know you kind of see it the
big kind of masters and when caps is
assemble everybody's standing there and
you know when we had all the actors on
set and and then depending on who we had
it's kind of dictated what would be CG
what what wouldn't be we had like a dirt
floor we had some wreckage and rubble
you know and some of that we would
replace depending on if it made it
easier to light the shot or the
composition it would get better but when
you get into the the portals opening up
you've got you know everybody on this
side of the portals you know with the CG
crater cg fire cg smoke cg atmosphere
CGM verse cg dusty g you know ash
floating around and then you've got the
portals themselves which they're their
own effects simulation complexity
simulation and then you've got all the
deities walking out we just didn't want
to make it feel like they're coming you
know from kind of this flat space where
you see the portal you wanted it to feel
like it's a dimensional space
yeah with marble to excuse it is the
shared universe everything's online
everything's in the archive so if you
need to go back and get contracts yet
you just go back and get contracts yeah
it's just there right so and then we had
kind of fell plush didn't you ask guard
so he did portions of new a scar so it's
like you you've got everything in this
world and plus everything from all the
other worlds that they're coming from so
it's it's you know it's almost
incalculable in terms of how much we
have we we then get into the battle you
get that wonderful scene calf rallying
everyone he assembles everyone charged
and you have a lot of you know actual
physical practical people and effects
and stuff they are charging into just a
hordes of enemies but those are all VFX
right ya know the before and afters and
those are the best before and afters
ever
parents of just you know in terms of
just the work that we did in just the
general comedy of what was actually
happening so if you look at the shots
and there's the shot where we begin kind
of the one er where you come in right
when with giant man punches the
Leviathan but you're zooming in on that
you've got all the heroes running
forward and you've got your actors there
and then there's maybe like six guys in
the motion capture suits running at them
again just to kind of let it kind of let
how the actors know generally where the
eyeline is for the approaching aliens
but yeah those antennas his army was
gonna yeah it's sometimes the befores
are just some of the oddly condley crude
things but it was something that yeah
work he got in there it was like you
know we're hooking it up we had the cuz
of the Big Shot where they kind of went
into the live action of everybody
together then you come up into the air
to see Chinamen punched Leviathan you go
back to CG and then you come back down
again on Panther and Akoya and Sheree
and that was shot as a separate little
piece on their set and then as you pan
left you got a little bit of a CG Drax
coming in that pulls you from that that
plans into the live-action dave bautista
let goes on this kind of I don't know
punching bag thing done guys hanging all
over it trying to make sure Dave didn't
fall off of it and then there's you know
the guy in the mocap suit for Korg which
is yep all of it it's this elegant
ballet it's really neat all right last
but not least we have to talk about one
of the the moments that made crowds roar
that gives you all the biggest feels
that's when we see all the women of
Marvel come together there on the
battlefield how much of that was filmed
practically how much was added in and
and how do you bring that all together
well we had everyone there it's like
there's like about two or three weeks
where him everybody's there you've got
every avenger from every movie that
we've done all on set at the same time
and so I mean it was it was a great day
to go to set it's like whoa miss pepper
there's you know there's a koi a you
know there's Valkyrie there's like you
know all these all the characters you
love are actually there on set so when
they when they all come together the
idea having this kind of passing of the
torch passing the gauntlet and there's a
lot of symbolism going on but then it
was also something that it was kind of
special to do to bring all the women of
Marvel together so we'll we shot it you
had everybody there Valkyrie we put in
later it's a different element cos she
was within the back of the Pegasus you
didn't have a practical Pegasus for this
we tried you know but again that's
probably like three years out you
cloning is two years now it's like but
but anyways you know she's landing in
the back so for the most part we had
everybody there and so you're you know
we go ahead and shot them you pull them
you lad you know Pepper's armor later
you'll have you know hope comes in is
the wasp and grows you so you'll
actually have angeline they're kind of
walking you know in the shot and they're
just gonna paint her out and then just
kind of you know have the wasps grow and
you know her size
I was sitting in a crowd opening night
and I watched the kid in front of me
jump up out of his chair arms up in the
air scream everybody's like crying and
laughing and cheering how how much fun
is it for you guys to put all this
together and to see it work but it gets
it's it's the best part you know it's
the you know we're all fans too right so
then you know there's all these moments
of you that you want to see and then for
us it's something that you know you see
it and pre this and you're kind of like
okay that's that's really cool it's
gonna be really great and so you see all
these scenes in pieces and you see them
kind of come together in editorial and I
remember the first time you know we kind
of cut the portals together and you know
Jeff Lord called me and he said take a
look you know and it's like I get a
little tear in the corner of your eye
and then you kind of like this is
kindness is gonna work and then any kind
of and part of the fun is then going it
to see what the real audience and it's
gonna see okay is this gonna work you
know and then you're sitting there
you're like oh my god this really works
there you go opening weekend and people
are just going nuts over and it's it's
like yeah I think that's the best part
and most rewarding part that you know
everything you know everybody loved what
we did which is great Dan thanks so much
for sharing so much about Marvel Studios
avengers end game you guys make sure you
pick up the film now